[موسيقى]
تتكون السماء من نجم وسدم ومجرات وكواكب
والعرب قسموا النجوم الى قسمين شماليه
وجنوبيه الشماليه يسمونها بالشاميه
والجنوبيه يسمونها باليابانيه ايا منكح
الثريا سهيلا عمرك الله كيف يلتقيان هي
شاميه اذا ما اطلت وسهيل اذا اطل يماني
فالشماليه هي الواقعه شمال خط الاستواء
وتدور حول قطبها الشمالي بين قوسين الجدي
والجنوبيه الواقعه شمال خط الاستواء
الجنوبي وتدور حول قطبها الجنوبي بولاريس
وهذه الاقطاب لا تتحرك من مكانها ليش
لانها تقع فوق مركز محور دورانها وين نجم
سهيل يا نجم الجدي همتي ترقى علامتنا
الغمام ما عليه الى طحت من عين الردي
طيحتي من عينه
ارفع للمقام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فالكواكب تعكس ضوء الشمس ساقط على وجهها
والسدم والمجرات تجمعات نجميه والنجوم
تخلق الضوء بذاتها مثل الشمس فالشمس نجم
متواضع تدرون النجم المشتري اكبر من الشمس
بخمس مرات فالشرق نحو الغربي اقرب شقه من
بعد تلك الخمسه الاشبال ان الكواكب في علو
محلها لترى صغارا وهي غير
صغاري
[موسيقى]